[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue c'est l'info
du vrai nous sommes ravis de vous
retrouver pour une heure et demie
d'actualité en direct comme chaque soir
sur canal + nous vous proposons ce soir
une émission en deux parties dès 19h10
l'info du vrai l'événement et ce soir
intitulé gilet jaune macron déclare la
riposte il l'a dit hier très clairement
s'il pouvait interdire les
manifestations il le ferait nous sommes
donc passés de des gilets jaunes et
macron à maquereau et les gilet jaune
on découvre par ailleurs que le
mouvement coûte de plus en plus cher
qu'on imaginait en tout cas aux
contribuables notamment dans nos grandes
villes où ça se chiffre maintenant
dizaines de millions le président at il
les moyens effectifs de la riposte pour
stopper la violence débat avec nos
invités dès 19h10 mais tout de suite
vive le réchauffement climatique il ya
un an à la même date nous portons tous
des anoraks et les températures étaient
négatives mais en ce moment ce n'est pas
le printemps mais littéralement l'été en
hiver du coup on nous sort tout
l'arsenal des limitations de vitesse et
de l'entrée dans les villes sur fond de
pollution et d'allergies aux pollens 1
27 février
ça peut surprendre alors que retenir en
fait de tout cela ces mesures ont-elles
une quelconque influence sur notre santé
et sur la survie de la planète nous
allons débattre avec nos spécialistes
mais tout de suite le premier reportage
de cette émission vite une période
tellement anxiogène que maintenant on
s'inquiète quand il fait beau
retour sur une pluie de records bien
agréable l'horaire peu et basile bonne
avec adrian dennis
pour ce père et sa fille cet après midi
l'activité ses châteaux de sable sur la
plage on va le nécessaire indispensable
pour s'amuser sur la plage a de quoi
faire des glaces aux sables d des
coquillages sable non les dunkerquois
n'ont pas perdu le nord
27 février 15 degrés sur la côte d'opale
ce n'est pas encore le printemps met à
regarder le ciel c'est tout comme
briller c'est un peu exceptionnel et
puis rien ça fait des jeux des petits et
les grands on est bien on est quand même
sans manteau sans foulard for money
c'est un âge ceux-là et le ciel bleu on
est super bien
un soleil de février à faire pâlir celui
du mois d'août 26 degrés à saint jean de
luz
c'est plus que les normales de l'été des
records de température qui tombent les
uns après les autres
certains vieux de plus de 50 ans 24
degrés à béziers 19 à noirmoutier 20 à
paris 16 degrés à la baule et les
premières baignades
on est passés pour des fous mais écoutez
nous on est orné passe après en bretagne
il fait toujours beau avant par tous
parce que c'est l'ouest et le beau temps
arrive par l'ouest
un hiver exceptionnellement doux les
bretons s'en amusent à météo-france en
revanche on s'inquiète depuis quinze
jours
ce prévisionniste a vu sa carte prendre
un gros coup de soleil
on voit en particulier que sur la région
du massif central mais également près
des ardennes on a eu des anomalies de
température de 12 à 14 degrés c'est à
dire qu'on était 12 à 14 degrés au
dessous de la normale on avait des
températures dignes d'une fin mai donc à
la fin du mois de février à paris alors
que le soleil s'était fait discret en
début d'année il n'a jamais autant
brillé pour un mois de février
cent trente sept heures d'ensoleillement
du jamais vu depuis le début des relevés
dans la capitale pour comprendre il
suffit de lever les yeux
pas un nuage dans le ciel on distingue
donc une europe de l'ouest protégé par
l'anti clown avec absolument aucun nuage
donc c'est tout à fait remarquable
notamment pour un mois de février
et puis on voit bien que les
perturbations les masses nuageuses
contourne cet anticyclone donc par le
sud du groenland par l'islande et puis
redescendre vers
l'est de l'europe un anticyclone
chasseur de nuages notamment les
stratocumulus ces nuages bas chargés en
eau est essentielle pour nous protéger
de la chaleur
la nasa a d'ailleurs imaginer un
scénario dans lequel ces nuages auraient
disparu une disparition qui ferait
bondir le thermomètre conséquence plus
lui degrés sur la planète
une étude alarmante d'un monde sans
nuage et qui se réchauffe dans lequel
nous ne sommes pas encore mais que les
spécialistes constatent un peu plus
chaque jour
en tant que maître log c'est une chose
que l'on que l'on vérifie gens me dire
tous les jours depuis de nombreuses
années on bat de plus en plus de records
de douceur et on va de moins en moins de
records de froid donc cet épisode de
grande douceur qui plus est durable et
cohérent avec le réchauffement
climatique
donc c'est effectivement un des
symptômes du réchauffement climatique et
il faut s'attendre dans les prochaines
années
pendant les prochaines décennies bien
sûr à avoir de plus en plus d'événements
doux précoce de ce type
un épisode douceur qui va pour l'instant
prendre fin nuages et pluies sont
attendues sur le pays dès demain est
avec nous pour commenter cette actualité
jean marc jancovici qui est ingénieur
consultant en énergie climat enseignant
à l'école des mines paristech vous
présidez par ailleurs le laboratoire
d'idées de shift project et est membre
du haut conseil pour le climat votre
dernier livre dormez tranquilles
jusqu'en 2100 et autre malentendu sur le
climat et énergie est paru chez odile
jacob martin perez est médecin et
journaliste médicale indépendante
on vous retrouve notamment sur pharma
radio est votre dernier livre cancer
qu'elle risque vient de paraître aux
éditions quae enfin emmanuel bocrie et
météorologistes et prévisionniste à
météo france où il dirige la division
média vous souvenez de du temps qui
faisait il ya un an très exactement
non pas tout à fait mais le temps qu'on
vit lieu en ce moment et comme ils
s'appellent d'exceptionnel j'aime j'ai
vérifié ce matin on était dans des
températures négatives et on était tous
en anorak je n'invente rien on a la même
date l'an dernier
t'es pas loin d'un épisode neigeux aussi
ma mémoire est bonne tout bravo donc il
faut savoir que non des épisodes de
douceur où vas-tu février on en a déjà
vécu mais on n'a jamais vécu quelque
chose d'aussi intense en durée et en
intensité
cet après midi au moins je sais que j'ai
quitté météo france on n'a pas encore
tous les valeurs de record mais au pied
des pyrénées au nord on enregistrait du
27 7 degrés côté les rennais orientale
et du 28/01 degré côté pyrénées
atlantiques oui ce qui est énorme on n'a
jamais vu ça actuellement on est en
train de battre une flopée de records de
températures pour un mois de février on
n'avait jamais vu ça
on a plus de 45 stations qui ont plus de
60 ans de mesures qui sont en train de
battre un record
on n'a pas encore l'état des chiffres
complets parce qu'il faut attendre la
fin de la journée
mais sait on n'a jamais vu tomber autant
de trois corps en un temps aussi court
je vous fais la remarque parce qu'elle
est réelle emmanuel bocrie vous êtes un
garçon tempéré et je ne cherche pas à
faire un jeune beau et c'est la première
fois que je vous vois nous dire avec
autant de on va dire de véhémence enfin
le cumul et si je comprends bien la
stabilité de ce qui se passe en ce
moment
alors on a beau revenir de façon très
simple arrêté on a un système
anticyclonique qui s'est installé sur la
france sur l'europe de one drop sur
l'europe de l'ouest via les str depuis
une quinzaine de jours
il est il est stable alors on n'a pas
d'explication exactement pourquoi il
reste aussi stable et on qu'on connaît
ce genre de phénomènes qui se produisent
et là on a toutes les conditions pour
que chaque jour on accumule un peu plus
d'énergie et là on est en train de
dépasser des valeurs qu'on avait jamais
enregistrée qui je vais vous dire un
truc idiot c'est que je le disais pour
débarrer l'émission l'atmosphère du pays
est tellement anxieux j'aime que
maintenant quand il fait bon sens en
inquiète plus que je vais je c'est pas
une plaisanterie c'est une réalité
j'ai envie de vous dire c'est quand même
bien agréable vous qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire comme commentaire que c'est
mettez en fait c'est très agréable parce
qu'on voit ça avec notre prisme du
roumain qui nous disent on tient c'est
sympa on peut aller à la plage quand on
la ville est juste à côté de la plage
combien de voir ou bien aller en
terrasse quand on allie terrasse etc et
on se dit comme l'urbain tout ça ne va
pas changer la quantité de nourriture
qui arrivent dans les supermarchés
le prix que ça va coûter le fait qu' on
va avoir suffisamment d'eau pour mener
nos activités correctement qui va pas y
avoir de prêtres sanitaires etc
vous êtes parfaitement lucide c'est
exactement ça donc on a une météo pour
humains parce que c'est là que vivent
les présentateurs météo et c'est là que
vivent les gens qui regardent la météo à
la télé pour l'essentiel est de plus en
plus de personnes sur la planète est de
plus en plus de personnes sur la planète
est en fait il faut quand même qu'on
comprenne que ce qui fait vivre la ville
se trouve en dehors de la ville c'était
accès pas dans la ville que push ce
qu'on mange c'est pas dans la ville que
pouces ce qui va nous permettre de nous
vêtir quand c'est des fibres textiles ou
que se trouvent les puits de pétrole
messaoud sujet quand on porte du
synthétique enfin et c'est donc il faut
qu'on comprenne qu en fait qui est en
train de se passer en ce moment enfin ou
plus exactement le le ce qu'on observe
aujourd'hui qui est cohérent avec une
évolution structurelle de long terme qui
est le réchauffement climatique va
déplacer et créer des choses inédites un
peu partout dont avec le temps une
fraction croissante nous sera adverse
c'est à dire que c'est malheureusement
le signe avant-coureur de quelque chose
qui plus tard et de façon inexorable à
cause de l'inertie du système va nous
amener de plus en plus de choses qu'on
risque pas trouvé très drôle
est ce que je peux vous dire ce que je
viens de comprendre ce que vous m'avez
dit et qui était donc parfaitement
claire et très agréable de boire une
petite bière avec modération j'ai
d'après-midi aux terrasses mais on va en
prendre plein la gueule parce qu'en fait
tout ça est en train de s'installer ça
va ça va avec quelque chose qui parvient
il fait beau la catastrophe arrive les
portes
ça va avec quelque chose qui est porteur
de danger mais il ya plein d'autres
choses qui sont
sympathique à court terme est porteuse
de dangers plus tard il ya quelques
clics faut bien comprendre le changement
climatique c'est que c'est un processus
qui n'est pas réversible
on a on oublie très souvent ça on a
l'impression que ça va ça vient bon le
jour on en aura vraiment assez on fera
ce qu'il faudra que les trucs sera
derrière nous malheureusement c'est pas
réversible parce que il faut attendre
des milliers d'années avant qu'un
surplus de co2 sans ail de l'atmosphère
oui donc quoi qu'on fasse aujourd'hui
sur les émissions les 20 prochaines
années sont celles et nous dire ce qui
va se passer sur les 20 prochaines
années ne dépend pas de ce qu'on va
faire à partir d'aujourd'hui donc si on
commence à réduire les émissions ce
qu'il faut faire demain matin on
travaille pour nos enfants qui sont par
ailleurs les générations futures
puissent qui n'étaient pas nés en 92
aller de la convention climat signe à
rio donc les il faut bien comprendre ça
c'est que on est vraiment en train de
voir en ce moment des choses qui sont
inédites et y en aura de plus en plus à
l'avenir et qui sont la traduction d'une
évolution qu'on ne peut pas arrêter à
court terme dont certains signes à très
court terme sont plutôt sympas oui
effectivement voilà ce matin terrasse au
soleil on a tous mal côté les trucs très
simple c'est le soleil c'est bon pour le
monde mais on ne peut pas avoir que du
soleil et de la chaleur et il faut se
rappeler que les indiens c'est la danse
de la pluie c'est que quand il est trop
beau pendant trop longtemps il trouvait
que ce n'est pas bien et du reste dans
votre civilisation on a sacrifié ce qui
lui tombait sous la main pour obtenir le
même résultat pas toujours de manière
très probante mais on essaye quand même
leur amour je loue ce matin il faisait
un temps absolument incroyable il fait
beau ce tome on en a quasiment jamais vu
le jeu et vous dire il fait beau en
allant du feu lui doivent être dépassé
les 20 degrés à l'anc ce qui est assez
étonnant
mais dans le même temps cet anticyclone
qu'ils apportent du beau temps sacré la
sécheresse
on manque d'eau sur la une grande partie
de la france actuellement donc s'il ya
des pour dessein de personnes sur une
population certaines activités
c'est une bonne chose pour d'autres ne
l'est pas rien je ne cultive pas le
scepticisme pour le plaisir mais vous
savez très bien que d'une certaine façon
beaucoup de ceux qui nous regardent se
disent c'est agréable c'est plaisant
finalement la météo il ya toujours eu
des écarts et puis après on s'en étonne
voilà donc la météo est quelque chose
dont nous sommes enfin nous sommes
difficilement crédible à expliquer des
choses parfaitement
sérieuse parce qu elle nous emmène loin
en arrière vous avez raison de en avant
pas d'aller moins loin en avant vous
avez vu raison de nous dire écoutez si
on fait des trucs aujourd'hui sa touche
nos enfants une vingtaine d'années et du
coup ça pose des problèmes
on peut dire aussi que ça manque
d'intelligence parce qu'on a une
incapacité à se projeter dans le futur
mais j'ai envie de vous dire que je
comprends qu'on ait un scepticisme par
rapport à ça ou quand sont inquiètes
peut-être pas à temps je comprends ce
que vous dites
il veut mais ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre aussi c'est que la situation
météo qu'on a actuellement elle nous
pose des problèmes au niveau là le côté
sympathique où effectivement on peut
aller en terrasse il fait beau c'est
vachement sympa avec cette terre on va à
la plage comme on l'a vu dans le report
ils achètent les gens prennent plaisir
mais dans le même temps on manque d'eau
donc ça va avoir un impact sur
l'agriculture et dans le même temps
aussi les conditions météo sont actuels
que sa favorite et épisode de pollution
atmosphérique
donc c'est tout un ensemble et puis je
vais venir juste une question qui n'est
pas une provocation martin perez est-ce
qu effectivement le soleil c'est bon
pour le moral mais bien sûr on a montré
et démontré que au niveau des yeux il ya
des capteurs qui font que certaines
hormones sont produites quand il ya du
soleil en particulier la sérotonine qui
est l'hormone du mode du bonheur entre
guillemets puisque c'est la sérotonine
constituent lé quand on ne prend des
antidépresseurs
donc ça a été démontré le soleil c'est
bon pas seulement pour le moral
d'ailleurs c'est bon parce que ça vous
fait fabriquer de la vitamine d
ça vous il ya pas mal d'impact sur la
santé ça permet aux personnes âgées de
sortir de chez elle parce que l'hiver
elles sont confinées
aujourd'hui j'ai traversé des jardins
biens et des personnes âgées qui était
pas sortie de chez elle depuis quelques
mois et qui était là dehors à prendre un
peu de soleil effectivement on parle de
deux sens différents
quand on parle de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui est de ce qui va se passer
dans les vingt ans lors de la même chose
et soudées sous des angles différents
bon donc nous confirmer que
on tournait bien dans la rue en
cependant ce n'est pas par hasard le
conseil biologiquement si je puis dire
notre corps répond et une stimulation
bien précises
oui c'est très important le soleil
d'abord parce que ça permet de sa
réguler lors de l'horloge biologique ça
beaucoup de fonctions biologiques
on n'est pas entré dans l'été quand même
j'ai ce qu'il va pleuvoir bientôt et est
ce que on peut se faire des épisodes
météorologiques alors dû du coup des
coups de froid en retour on peut en
avoir des coups de froid donc arrêter si
on prend tout simplement une séquence en
train de brûler actuellement
elle va se finir demain demain après
midi on va avoir une rentrée de nuages
sur la streif de la france un petit peu
de vent
localement un petit peu puis on va
rentrer dans un système perturbé
dimanche on aura certainement soit d'une
perturbation qui rentrera les personnes
issues de la france ont une sensation
encore de beau temps
parce qu il fera doux encore pas trop
froid en altitude les gens qui sont
hostiles eux vont voir la différence les
températures vont chuter entre
aujourd'hui les jours à venir de 10 à 15
degrés donc ils ont vraiment le sentir
c'est énorme ça il va y avoir de la
neige au-dessus valoir la neige
au-dessus dans les alpes au dessus de
1500 mètres on devrait avoir de l'ordre
de 10 cm de neige donc c'est une bonne
chose pour les stations de ski nom
revient dans un cycle de perturbations
qu'il y a lieu en hiver au mois de
février au mois de mars c'est ce que de
toute façon tout à fait classique dit
mieux on évoquait dans le reportage
c'est questions soulevées par la nasa
notamment a dit qu'on allait perdre un
certain nombre de nos nuage et que s'il
disparaissait réellement ce serait à 8
degrés de plus pour l'humanité alors
hein est-ce que c'est sérieux possible
et envisageable
il faut savoir le niveau de sous c'est
terrifiant alors l'évolution de la
couverture nuageuse dans un monde qui se
réchauffe sait depuis longtemps un point
dur de la modélisation et c'est un des
éléments qui fait que les divers modèles
ya à peu près une vingtaine de modèles
aujourd'hui dans le monde pour les gens
qui étudient l'avenir du climat
oui la divergence entre modèles sur le
fait que certains donnent des résultats
sensiblement différents d'autrui ça
tient pour beaucoup à la façon dont il
voit l'évolution de la couverture
nuageuse a donc ce point il est déjà
identifiées depuis longtemps donc pas d
mais là on est au coeur du système même
dans le débat scientifique absolument
est par ailleurs selon la couverture
nuageuse qu'on favorise le résultat en
plus ce n'est même pas le même parce que
si vous faites un peu plus de cyrus qui
sont des nuages de haute altitude très
translucide
qui sont composés de vapeur d'eau aussi
et donc il participe à l'effet de serre
parce que la vapeur d'eau participe à
l'effet de serre
vous allez globalement augmenté l'effet
de serre si vous rajoutez des cirrus
comme des traits des condensations des
avions soit dit en passant les alors que
si vous augmentez des cumulus là par
contre globalement ils ont un effet
réfléchissant plus important que leur
effet de serre donc en fonction des
nuages qui voit là du type de nuage qui
apparaît en plus ou en moins vous avez
un effet qui ne portent pas le même
signe sur l'évolution globale du climat
donc tout ça est parfaitement alors je
connais pas l'étude de la nasa j'ai pas
lu celle là dans d'autres détails
par contre le fait que depuis longtemps
il ya un débat scientifique au sein de
la communauté sur le fait que
l'évolution sera plus ou moins rapide en
fonction de ce qui va se passer sur la
couverture nuageuse ça c'est un débat
ancien j'ai envie de dire qu'il ya
quelques dizaines d'années
donc faut prendre soin de nos nuage vous
rappeler ce qu'on appelle exactement un
stratus ou et un cumulus en quelques
mots le cumulus et le petit le petit
nuage un peu bourgeonnant la balle de
coton convoi alors en été qui est beau
le stratocumulus c'est une accumulation
de ces cumulus qui vont s'étaler en find
halde de nuages plutôt bas et les cyrus
dont parlait jean marc jancovici
ce sont des nuages qui sont sous forme
de cheveux d'altitude qui sont
essentiellement composés de glace et
après vous avez les dix types de nuages
on voit évoluer nos nuage et s par des
mois est ce qu'on envoie 10 par sas
évalue la quantité nuages alors
pardonnez moi c'est pas un phénomène
stable
vous comprenez ma qu'à l'être humain un
être humain aura beaucoup de mal à
évaluer parce que c'est quelque chose
les nuages évolue en permanence un nuage
n'est pas quelque chose de statique un
nuage se transforme en permanence si
vous mettez cet été où il allongé dans
l'herbe ou regarder le ciel je vous le
recommande
vous verrez que les nuages bougeant
permanent permettre des formes en
permanence il se transforme en
permanence là la seule façon dont on
peut mesurer réellement comment évoluent
nos nuage c'est essentiellement par
l'observation 17es avec grâce au
satellite
et ça c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
pointu mais l'être humain depuis sol on
a dû beaucoup de mal à s'en rendre
compte
bon j'ai bien compris que quasiment sur
votre première intervention vous avez
dit on a un problème parce qu'il faut
quand même qu'il pleuve et il faut
rééquilibrer nos sols d'ailleurs tous
les deux vous étiez parfaitement
d'accord là dessus ce qui donc suggèrent
d'éventuels problèmes pour l'agriculture
alors
moi je passe toujours quand on a des un
épisode comme ça quelques coups de fil
en province vous savez on est tantôt
grand-mère et ses bras et à l'ancienne
où lola là il fait très beau pendant le
mois de février alors ça c'est pas bon
pour le printemps on n'aura pas un bel
été je vous laisse commenter et avec nos
grands mères non je ne réponds pas ses
patientes ific moi j'ai une réponse par
contre il augmente à un rythme lent ça
augmente un risque sur la végétation
c'est que la végétation des bourgs
plutôt et ça on a eu cet épisode début
de l'année dernière voilà et du coup si
vous avez un gel qui est entre
guillemets normales pour la saison
dans un mois la vous pouvez dire adieu à
la récolte de fruits et ça affaiblit la
végétation par ailleurs donc c'est ça le
c'est surtout ça le problème que vous
pouvez avoir deux il peut ya voir ça il
peut lui aussi être des plantes qui ont
besoin d'avoir un coup de froid pour
repartir
si l on passe coup de froid elles
n'arriveront pas à se développer
correctement donc ça peut avoir un
impact sur les quantités de prélèvement
et fruitiers sont souvent comme ça
recruter alors février n'est donc pas
encore terminée mais d'ores et déjà
record là encore battu regarde
l'ensemble de 2010 huit brefs combats
dont le bois par des mois on barre et
non pas en bois un nombre de jours de
fortes pollutions de l'année passée et
je ne vous parle même pas des pollens on
va parler donc aussi de notre santé
vincent farnese vini
paul devine être critères jeu
foulard aujourd'hui certains n'étaient
pas équipés ou pas informés
pourquoi vous êtes dans la zone
d'arrêter interdisant la circulation aux
véhicules n'ayant pas de ginette donc
gens vous inviter à faire demi tour pour
la première fois à lille la circulation
différenciée a été mise en place suite
relevé de pollution qui sont transmises
monsieur le préfet la décision
d'abaissement des vitesses qui avaient
été prises au cours des journées n'a pas
permis de baisser significativement la
pollution et donc nous sommes passés
lignée de critères chose qui avait déjà
été prévu et préparé en préfecture
depuis depuis de plusieurs années et
donc qui a été mise en place pour la
première fois aujourd'hui même système à
paris où 350 policiers sont mobilisés
jusqu'à minuit les deux métropoles peine
à respirer
victime d'un pic de pollution aux
particules fines et les conséquences sur
la santé sont multiples la pollution
augmente l'asthme elle serait
responsable de 15 à 30 % des maladies
respiratoires et cardiovasculaires les
risques de cancer sont également majorés
et certaines allergies peuvent être
aggravées notamment celle au pollen les
températures printanières en plein mois
de février des règles le calendrier des
pollens qui arrivent beaucoup plus tôt
que d'habitude les cyprès par exemple
très allergène entre normalement
pollinisation fin mars mais ils ne sont
pas les seuls on trouve déjà sur tout le
territoire
les pollens des zones noisetiers ou
graminées onze départements sont en
alerte rouge à l'endroit concerné
la météo clémente fait que les pollens
sont en grande grande quantité avec plus
de vent qu'avant aussi et ça c'est un
cofacteur important de dispersion des
pollens dans l'air on sait que les
pointes du cyprès peuvent faire
plusieurs centaines de kilomètres
aujourd'hui entre 25 et 30 % des
français sont allergiques aux pollens
c'est quatre fois plus qu'il ya 40 ans à
cause notamment du réchauffement
climatique
la première c est ce que les mesures
je vous demande un avis qui sont prises
notamment de limitation de la
circulation ou un quelconque effet un
quelconque intérêt selon vous à court
terme pour nous protéger
parce que si vous voulez mon avis
aujourd'hui on a encore fait des
bataillons de gilet jaune donc quand on
dit à quelqu'un demi tour du rand pas en
ville aujourd'hui à lille ou à wawa
paris sont des mesures raisonnables
voilà en fait quand vous regardez la
carte de la pollution à ça dépend de
quelle pollution on parle si on
s'intéresse aux particules fines
oui les quand vous regardez les cartes
de présence de particules fines en
europe
vous voyez que les concentrations sont
en fait des choses qui varient à large
échelle c'est à dire que quand vous avez
un camp quand on est un épisode de
pollution toute l'europe du nord par
exemple est couverte dans un gros nuage
rouge de particules fines est donc à ce
moment que vous soyez en ville pas en
ville peut pas être en ville l'origine
fa la circulation ne joue pas un rôle
déterminant dans l'apparition de ces
particules donc je pense que c'est une
mesure qui est plus symbolique qu'autre
chose
à ce stade c'est très difficile de
savoir d'où viennent les particules
rendez compte de ce que vient de me dire
ça on en mer des milliers de gens ici il
faut être raisonnable c'est bon les
emmerdes sur quelque chose qui est
facile à faire parce que sur les mesures
qui sont plus structurelles c'est plus
difficile
vous avez par exemple une grosse source
de particules qui est toute
l'électricité au charbon qui est
produite dans l'europe du nord oui et on
voit bien quand il ya des comptes des
vents d'est des vents du nord-est les
nuages de particules qui arrive sur la
france c'est plus facile de demander
quelque chose à l'automobiliste français
quand vous êtes préfet de police en
france que demander quelque chose aux
électriciens allemands
facile donc en fait vous êtes obligé
quelque part quand vous êtes l'état de
montrer que vous faites quelque chose
vous êtes un peu obligé tous les gens
qui passent sur ce plateau vous leur
demande
qu'est ce que vous faites ils sont bien
obligés de vous dire qu'ils font quelque
chose c'est rare qu'ils acceptent de
vous dire là on n'y peut rien non donc
il ya une partie de la pollution vous ai
déjà entendu tenir des propos de ce type
qui étaient des propos sincères et
honnêtes et qui sont le fait d'un grand
scientifique donc je pense que tout
autre on peut dire la vérité aux
français qu'ils sont assez intelligents
pour la comprendre c'est un autre débat
je suis maintenant mais c'est un long et
intéressant débat général d'accord avec
vous mais voilà donc ça c'est donc il
faudrait mesurer en fait il faudrait
faire des double aveugle chose qu'on n'a
absolument pas là il faut faire des
études épidémiologiques dans ce genre de
contexte je pense que dans 253 gens on y
arrivera toujours pas donc c'est très
difficile de savoir si effectivement ça
a une efficacité
martin perez l'avis du médecin oui c'est
assez compliqué vous savez la pollution
atmosphérique cd multiples sources et
bien sûr la pollution automobile et à la
pollution industrielle et centrales au
charbon
mais même des phénomènes naturels et
blanc des sables qui amène ya les
intuitions de la culture dans tout ça ce
se mélangent dans l'air avec entre les
particules et différents types de gaz
donc c'est assez compliqué mais vous
avez raison on peut pas arrêter les
centrales à charbon d'allemagne c'est
difficile d'arrêter les éruptions
volcaniques ou les vans des sables on
peut pas arrêter notre vie industrielle
qui déjà se porte pas très bien et on
essaye d'agir sur les sur ce qu'on peut
c'est-à-dire la pollution d'origine
automobile qui a beaucoup baissé
d'ailleurs ces dernières années
sincèrement je pense que ça nourrit le
populisme
enfin je suis sur ce on sait aujourd'hui
que la pollution automobile augmente la
pollution particulaire oui il n'y a pas
de raisons aux périodes de pollution
parce que comme l'air ce tag ne bouge
pas de ne pas essayer de prendre ce
genre de mesures
d'ailleurs la preuve c'est que souvent
les gens ne sont pas rebelle un accès
assez bien accepté ça dure deux ou trois
jours on n'a pas créé de révolution et
je crois pas que les gilles les jaunes
vont s'en émouvoir comme vous avez je
pense vous sent très inquiet là dessus
c'est sûr que ça va je suis pas d'accord
des couples c'est pas le problème
les américains publié une étude
incroyable ce matin dont on s'est fait
écho en indiquant 22 mille morts
prématurés dus au diesel dont 66 % de
ces décès serait dû au diesel
est ce que des études de ce type vous
semble aujourd'hui argumenté et sérieuse
et a eu beaucoup d'études sur la
mortalité liée à la pollution alors en
france et quelques années et s'il ya ça
fait la une de tous les journaux on a
estimé qu'il y avait 48 mille morts liés
à la pollution mais souvent quand les
journaux évoquent ce genre d'étude il
n'explique pas du tout de quoi il s'agit
quand on parle de 48000 mende on peut je
vais pas vous je vais être incapable de
vous dire mon grand père ou ma grand
mère aimante de la pollution ça on ne
sait pas ce sont des évaluations
statistiques ce sont des projections
alors qu'est ce qui se passe quand un
pic de pollution on examine les taux de
mortalité dans les grandes villes
et on regarde ce qui se passe or on a pu
constater il ya eu des études assez
poussées qui ont montré que lors des
pics de pollution les personnes fragile
c'est à dire en a sur ce gardien comme
suit 11 respiratoire avait un risque
accru de décès d alors mais est-ce qu'il
meurt vraiment de la pollution ou de la
maladie qu'il ont en réalité il ya de
calcul encore plus approfondis qui ont
montré que ces personnes-là perdaient
entre quelques semaines et 8 mois
d'espérance de vie quand on est en bonne
santé aujourd'hui en tout cas on meurt
pas de la pollution je vous dise les
derniers chiffres disait que donc c'est
48 mille personnes qui décideraient très
naturellement de quelques mois due à la
pollution
alors maintenant se pose le phénomène
des pollens
j'ai connu une époque on en parle est
absolument pas et où j'ai où on
s'interrogeait absolument pas de savoir
si nos enfants allaient être allergique
et maintenant tout le monde se dit
touché à tous les âges de la vie et
et ça remplit les les bureaux et les
officines de vos confrères et aux
consorts allergologue
et alors et alors seconde question c'est
est-ce que si les pollens sont en train
de sortir en ce moment ça veut dire que
la nature se réveille trop tôt et
qu'elle peut se prendre un coup deux
fois derrière alors on va le faire en
deux temps déjà sur notre santé les
pollens d'abord nombre de personnes
allergiques a beaucoup augmenté au cours
des trente dernières années alors il ya
beaucoup d'explications et ça c'est pas
seulement la pollution
d'abord il ya la pollution de l'air
intérieur il ya des experts d
immunologie ce qu'ils disent
aujourd'hui on soigne trop les
infections des enfants les plus protège
trop il ya un excès d'hygiène qui fait
que leur système immunitaire ceux des
deux ne combat plus les affections mes
combats des choses qui seraient qui sont
des éléments naturels et effectivement
l'allergie au pollen est devenu quelque
chose de complètement fou et de très
important la pollution est un facteur de
risque de l'exacerbation de l'allergie
au pollen
parce que quand vous êtes exposés au pot
l'aide et à la pollution
eh bien il ya une inflammation des
bronches qui facilite la pénétration des
pollens dans l'arbre bronchique et au
niveau respiratoire et qui fait qu'il ya
une exacerbation de tous les symptômes
et puis comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure
la saison des pollens augmenté beaucoup
plus long qu'avant on ça commence en
février
plus le pic de pollution voilà vous avez
des gens j'ai quelques amis tout à
l'heure au téléphone comme vous je passe
quelques coups de vérité ce temps là et
j'entendais des éternuements des to
d'aidé qui coule et on me demandait
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire une étude
américaine qui étaient référencés par
nos confrères de sud ouest ce matin qui
montrait que la préparation du dîner de
thanksgiving donc en gros le rôti dans
le four générait dans un appartement
beaucoup plus de pollution aux
particules fines que n'importe quelle
sortie à l'extérieur je sais pas si
c'est le président de 3m qui a financé
le l'enquète non mais voilà si on a en
permanence des aspects contradictoires
mais ce que vous nous livrent notamment
ce soir
jean marc jancovici c'est que le long
terme reste long terme et que les
échéances à plusieurs années on les
connaît elles sont claires et elles sont
effectivement inquiétante
moi ce que je dis c'est qu'on va avoir
de plus en plus de choses qui vont nous
surprendre
c'est là c'est le propre d'une situation
qui change si ça change c'est une
lapalissade ce que je vais dire mais si
ça change c'est que c'était pas comme
avant et si c'est pas comme avant c'est
que ça va nous surprendre parce que ça
va avoir un aspect différent
une autre chose qui est bien connue des
dans le monde scientifique c'est que
dans le dans le cadre d'un climat qui se
réchauffe par supplément d'effet de
serre
l'élévation des températures est plus
marqué l'hiver que l'été oui et plus
marquée au pour le coc tropiques là je
sais pas quelle est l'anomalie de
température qu'on constate l'été par
rapport aux normales en ce moment mais
je pense qu'en ce moment c'est encore au
dessus la hausse en ce moment au dessus
des températures est d'aider normal ça
c'est clair on les a franchement dépassé
dès ce que dit jean marc jancovici est
tout à fait vrai avec le changement
climatique on va avoir des perturbations
du cycle qu'on connaît actuellement
oui qui aura des conséquences énormes
lesquels il y en a qui sont très simples
y en a bon il ya les canicules qu'on
connaît du compte on sait qu'ils vont
apparaître
on sait que des endroits où on manque
d'eau pouvoir m'en occupe encore
peut-être en plus d'endroits on va en
avoir de trop alors on va dire trop doba
vous peut le gérer sauf que c'est faux
non vous prenez les canalisations
d'évacuation d'eau des villes
aujourd'hui elles sont calculées pour
une certaine quantité d'eau si c'est
trop important
ça déborde de tous les côtés elles ont
été calculés pour le temps que nous
avions que nous avions il ya trente ou
cinquante ans il n'y a pas que les
canalisations il ya l'exemple récent du
queensland là où il ya eu des années de
sécheresse et puis tout d'un coup des
inondations absolument massive
c'est un bon exemple ou en moyenne il
est tombé de l'eau mais voilà une en
moyenne mais elle est tombée très
brutalement quand même au même titre
qu'on pense par exemple aux cyclones on
sait quelle crise vite avec le
changement climatique des cyclones ou
nora peut pas avoir autant
simplement on risque d'avoir des
épigones beaucoup plus violent que sont
là actuellement
donc comme on sait que l'homme a une
tendance à se mettre long des côtes
il va on y va on voit très vite les a
pas que ça va avoir retenu quelques
endroits
regardez la floride c'est extrêmement
peuplée regardez la chine avec toutes
ses usines tillous-borde c'est quasiment
en bordure de mer donc dès qu'il ya un
cyclone ça devient catastrophique ont
détruit complètement toute
l'infrastructure de du pays en question
convient d'observer le plus puissant
jamais observée dans l'hémisphère nord
un mois de février là dans le pacifique
oui oui vous beauty une katie outils oui
on parle du réchauffement climatique
ce qu'on parle bien de l'ensemble de la
planète et est ce que nous sommes tous
en tant qu'humanité concerné je pense
que c'est très important de le rappeler
parce qu'on est fait quand on juge
depuis la terrasse du café a parlé haut
et lorient s'est pour l'instant plutôt
agréable oui oui et puis les et encore
une fois les effets les plus inquiétants
sont les effets sont peuvent être les
effets qu'ils prennent leurs racines le
plus loin il ya eu un peu d'actualité
récemment sur ce qui se passe en ce
moment sur la calotte antarctique
vous avez un glacier là qui est en train
de se désagréger à vitesse accélérée
alors pour faire simple la calotte
antarctique de l'ouest celle qui est
face au chili là c'est un vaste système
barque boudant glaciaire dans lequel la
calotte est maintenue en équilibre par
chaque glaciers qui s'appuie sur son
voisin en gros et il ya des vraies
inquiétudes sur le fait que si on passe
les femmes de degré de l'accord de paris
qu'on va passer puisqu'on a déjà passé
un ennemi tard on est déjà on a déjà
signé pour un an et demi quoi qu'on
fasse
et bien cette calotte pourrait se
désagréger dans un temps qui avant on
pensait que ces quelques siècles
aujourd'hui on se dit on sait pas oui
même plus et ça c'est si m dos en plus
pour l'océan mondial donc la même
personne qui se réjouit de prendre une
bière en terrasse en ce moment se
réjouit du début d'un processus qui va
peut-être mettre dunkerque sous la
flotte et bordeaux sous la flotte et
miami sous la flotte et shanghai sous la
flotte etc
et je doute que tout ça conduisent tout
le monde à boire des bières en terrasse
dans la paix et la bonne humeur
donc non mais voilà donc c'est lui c'est
ça en fait le sujet c'est qu'on voit
avec un oeil mais c'est normal on est
des animaux c'est ce qui a été dit tout
à l'heure je veux dire moi aussi je suis
content quand éducation non mais on
réagit de manière biologique c'est
normal c'est tout à fait normal mais il
faut qu'on fasse un effort d'abstraction
pour comprendre que ça va avec quelque
chose d'autre qu'on risque pas trouvé
drôle du tout alors en matière
d'abstraction j'ai une bonne nouvelle à
besoin que l'alerté est levée à paris
donc ce soir à partir de minuit jeudi
bien partir de minuit donc deux morts
jeudi
vous pourrez circuler normalement sans
vos fameuses vignettes critères qui
limite en partie la circulation c'est le
cas aujourd'hui
aussi vous le savez à lille merci
beaucoup les uns les autres d'avoir
participé à cette première partie
d'émission de là dans un instant l'info
du vrai l'événement qui est intitulé ce
soir matheron déclare la riposte on va
parler gilet jaune et réponse
présidentielle a tout de suite
[Musique]